vous avez une minute partons pour le
village d'irréductible du tarte gaudran
où le papa d'asterrix Albert huderzo a
laissé une empreinte indélibile bien
au-delà de ses célèbres bande
dessiné il y a plus de 20 ans huderzo
s'est impliqué dans la vie communale en
rejoignant le conseil municipal du maire
Jean-Luc le Romain e le Romain vous êtes
des
romaines c'est avec un clin d'œil
artistique il a redessiné le blason de
la ville s'inspirant de celui de Paris
mais au radeau de la capitale il a
préféré un sabot flottant et il a
revisité la devise fluctua necmergiture
en necmergiture item car le petit
village comme la Ville Lumière ne sombre
jamais mais son engagement ne s'est pas
arrêté là puisque l'un des chemins qui
mène à sa propriété a été rebaptisé allé
de la serpe d'or en hommage à l'un de
ses albums l'esprit du petit gaulois
Astérix reste bien vivant avec une 40e
aventure qui vient d'être publiée fin
octobre l'iris blanc de nouveaux auteurs
aux commande la bande dessinée a été
tirée à plus de 5 millions d'exemplaires